hello everyone this next game was played
in 1971 in Vancouver Canada and it was
the quarter final candidates match for a
world championship and I already showed
you one game in Bobby Fischer's match
against the bent Larsen and I show you
knew that one game in his metric and
stigman Petroleum so I thought it would
only be fair to show you one game he
played against to mark Simonov but not
just any game this is the famous Game
three of the match Fischer taimanov and
well it was it was a very intense game
because game number two Bobby Fischer
won game number one and game number two
was adjourned
and then while playing game number three
Fischer got an offer from the Soviets to
resign game number three and then and
then time I would agree to a draw in
game number two so after three rounds of
the match if the score would be tied and
well it would be an even field but Bobby
Fischer refused this offer and ended up
winning both game 1 game 2 and game 3
and this was a this was a terrible thing
for mark timing of mark diamond of lost
the entire match six to zero and well
the Soviets were were very embarrassed
and well they they they deprived the
time enough of his citizenship and they
took his salary they expelled him from
society for two years they censored him
in the press and it was it was easier
for the Soviets to you know make Simon
of disappear than to have this
embarrassment walking among among them
because there was just no way that the
Soviets could lose to an American with a
result like six to zero even though
after the game Fischer said that well
even though the result is as it is it's
in no way a reflection of diamond of
real strength but it's how it happened
and only years later this time of wrote
wrote his book how I became Fischer's
victim and well hence the title of the
video but let's see this famous game
three mark tomorrow is white and Bobby
Fischer is black we have d4
the time I love really prepare for this
game because he knew that the Bobby
Fischer would go for his King Indian and
he prepared a very special treat
Bobby plays Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to
c3 and Bishop to g7 the Kings Indian
defense
efore b6 Knight to f3 castles Bishop to
e2 a Fisher goes 85 castles nice to see
six now d5 Knight to e7 Bishop to b2 and
faker plays a nice to e8 and this is a
standard theme in the Kings Indian
defense but I want to play a five and
then push the pawns on the Kings side
and go for go for King side attack
we have rocked the c1 and now have five
by Fisher time I will place Queen Queen
to b3 we have V 6 by Fischer he captures
and f5 and now G captures on f5 and a
nice a g5 since the Fisher already
played at five he weakened this ecig
square and if if Fischer wants to get
rid of this night you will have to play
h6 and then further we can heal skin
Kings position so nice to have six by
Fischer and now f4 and Fischer does play
h6 he wants to get rid of this night we
have F casters on e5 first now he
captures and D captures on e5 and
probably it's it's okay to let the play
nice back to f3 but Simon of decides to
go for for four more active move and
place three five and well this isn't
really a peace sacrifice as if H
captures on g5 tamanna would play d6
with a check check to the king and then
winning the piece back and with an open
H file this would be this would be
somewhat better for white so after c5
Fischer actually finds the best idea in
the poison ice s casters on d5
we have Knight captures on d5 and now
again Knight captures on d5 and this is
a pretty good position for diamond of
and he would really like to play Bishop
to c4 here to pin this night but Fischer
has this c6 move so time ago finds the
brilliant idea he plays the see capture
some b6 and now of course see capture
son b6 is impossible because the Fischer
needed needs this C pawn to be able to
play c6 so he has to play a a capture
some b6 and now time I'll place a rook
to c6 and this is a great move as it
prevents the salmon out from playing c6
after Bishop to c4 which is now a great
threat but this wrote the c6 move also
prevents the Bishop to e6 so Fisher
can't really protect this night and time
I have said that after he played this
Bishop wrote the c6 move that he was
completely heard that he was winning and
that he would win this game and well
actually Fischer finds the only move
that that continues the game for black
they only move in the position and he
plays King to h8 and this is the
critical position of the game and time
of said even after this King 2hh move he
was so sure that he was winning and he
was he was thinking about the move Queen
to h3 and this would well if he plays
wind h3 the threat is pretty simple if
for example if black plays a full move
like Bishop to B so in the thread is
Rick Kester's and h6 and this is forced
amazing to whatever black plays for
example King to g8 rook to h8 check the
king can go to 7 because it's covered by
the knight the only movies for the
bishop to capture the rook and then
simply Queen to h7 checkmate so this was
definitely definitely a good idea but
after Queen to h3
well he just have to consider a lot of
things like rook the s6 protecting and
to Knight to f6 and the taimanov
actually spends 72 minutes so 1 hour and
12 minutes on this move and in the end
he couldn't find the he didn't find a
good good continuation for white and in
the end he plays Knight to f3 and he
says that after he plays this Knight to
f3 move he was so exhausted and he was
he was so angry with himself and he said
I've been playing chess my whole life
and I'm playing the candidates match for
the World Championship and I can't find
a win
winning position and he didn't know what
was going on if Fisher was really this
strong he said that he was starting to
consider that Fisher was was
invulnerable and well after this night
of three he was really exhausted and
well he was he was also very down in
time
so fever plays Bishop to be seven
attacking that's broken c6 we have a
rope the g6 it's a pretty good square
for the rook but this allows Fischer to
play Knight to f4 now attacking this
rook and also the bishop on e - so the
Knight has to be captured time enough
captures this and Fischer captures ekx
resign at four and now Fischer has a
nice bitter pair but both of these
bishops are extremely strong now so we
have roof to d1 attacking the Queen
Queen to e7 and now attacking the bishop
and to rope the e6 and the Queen to c5
check King to s1 and now look a to d8
official now wants to exchange rooks as
he is well up upon we have rook casters
and e8 rook captures and e8 and Queen to
a4 and Fisher plays Queens the c1 check
King to f2 and our Bishop tests fate and
this Bishop to f8 is a direct response
to the screen to a four move the idea of
Queen to a4 was a time I wanted to play
rook the rook to e8 which check and to
exchange this rock of course and then
put a screen on the eighth rank but this
bishops a face idea kind of stops this
now now rook to e8 is without a check so
he plays b4 and now Fischer replace a
Bishop to b4 a very nice centralizing
move Fischer and well time ago plays
rook to e8 now threatening to capture
this Bishop anaphase and also well after
after the rooks are exchanged then this
Queen would be extremely strong here but
this was actually a Fisher's idea now I
don't know if Simon of missed Fischer's
next move because I didn't read Timon of
the book although I am planning to so I
don't know if this is a blunder by time
I know because
you know in time trouble or did he
willingly go into this but he lost
Fischer to play Bishop to c6 now
attacking both Queen and the rook here
and well time on of his next move is
pretty much forced he plays Queen
captures and c6 given up the Queen for
two pieces Queen captures on c6 and rook
captures and e8 and well okay he does
have two pieces for the Queen but that
the coordination between white pieces
isn't that great and well it'd be maybe
a lot better if this was a dark squared
Bishop here but but it's not so we have
point six defending the bishop and also
attacking the rook every tempo is
important in positions like this rope
the c8 now Queen to e7 we have King to
f1 King to h7 getting out of the pin
nice to d4 Bishop to g7 attacking the
knight Knight to b5
Bishop to e5 protecting that c7 pawn a3
Queen to d7 and this is now well almost
over
Fischer finds a very nice continuation
to to go for the win
he attacked the rook and after rook to a
a he plays f3 now forcing White's to
capture here so G captures an f3 and now
Bishop captures on h2 King to g2
attacking the bishop and now Fischer
seemed to place Queen to g7 check the
time on of captures the bishop and now
Queens the e5 check now attacking this
Bishop to the world so King to g1 and
after taimanov played King did you want
he also resigned the game because well
after the Queen captures this Bishop to
the coordination between whites pieces
is simply is simply bad he's attacking
the knight and for example if he was
white were to play a four well the CB
simply f4 is completely winning and he
will win this poem and this f-bomb would
rush down the board and this is quickly
over so yeah like I said this is game
number three and Fischer continued to
win all six games so a very nice result
by Fischer of six six to zero and these
candidates match
were actually they were supposed to be
10 10 games matches but since 50160 it's
impossible for time enough to win the
match so the match was over same as it
was with bent Larsen on only Tigran
Petrosian managed to play more than six
games in his match against Fischer so
yeah a very nice a very nice game and
I'm interested in any if any of you have
read a timeless book how I became
Fischer's victim and yeah that's it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you all for
watching
I do wanna I do want to thank Henrik
Johan legi for your contribution to my
channel I really appreciate it and I
will see you soon guys